what is the latest on the shooting who  did this and why  tarnation the death toll has gone up to  more than 140 more of the dead students  the bites what we got from Horrible the  total attack of strong increase start  school picked up by one by one and shot  them on and showed them on blank and has  been the government's response only  continue Cameron  what about the fear of reprisals at this  point are we hearing anything for  government or police officials about  perhaps more planned attacks said that  they got some  and definitely they are saying that  they're gonna be are actually against  those who were involved in in the attack